i don't like to kick a guy when he's
down but this is a truly loathsome
creature
former media darling michael avenatti
heading to prison the disgraced lawyer
will spend
two and a half years behind bars for
trying to extort
nike for 25 million bucks he was
apparently weeping in the courtroom
today in his legal troubles far from
over
avenatti faces two more trials on the
west coast
the media looking very foolish after
praising this creep
to me you're like the holy spirit you
are all places
at all times looking ahead to 2020 one
reason why i'm taking you seriously as a
contender
is because of your presence on cable
news i wrote about this saying you're
currently leading the pack
among 2020 contenders on the democratic
side
look i think you're doing a hell of a
job i don't think you're in this for
money
[Laughter]
we used to share it office chris and i
see nbc uh so dana is
is this uh that affection they showed
avenatti was that
that avenatti qualities or was that
really about hating trump
i think that it was just like getting
carried away with themselves like within
the hopes that
maybe somebody would be able to take on
donald trump at the time
and michael avenatti he craved the media
attention he
he was always available i mean that's
the easiest date in town
and the thing is also he was quite
behind the times
what you do now if you want to get 25
million dollars from a company is you
have
basically you go underground and ask
them for 20 you know 50 million dollars
in crypto
and that's how you get paid like this he
doesn't even know what he's doing
anymore but you become a diversity
consultant
and you introduce and you come in and
wokify the corporation
you could do that as well but i'm glad
that justice was done here and i'm
really glad also that nike's lawyers
sniffed this out immediately contacted
the fbi that guy's driving ferraris he's
wearing uh two thousand dollar suits and
he's uh where's the money coming from
uh so what about stormy doug uh daniels
you think she should uh
is they what daniels daniels yeah i like
how you
remember now you forget her name how can
you forget stormy
he got 30 months that's uh one month for
every hair on his head
i'm curious will brian stelter or jeff
zucker visit him in jail after all
they were you know
[Laughter]
jessie waters nothing wrong with that
but how does cnn report this i mean it's
like michael avenatti a lawyer we just
heard about today
we did not party with him there are no
pictures of us with don lemon in the
hamptons
uh he just went to jail and we are so
happy that he went to jail
and we have nothing to do with them how
else are they gonna report on it
because they pushed this guy on america
because to your
question to dana they were deluded by
their
their uh well their delusional loathing
of donald trump just got they
if this guy was like a mass murderer
they still would have
but it is very clear evidence of that
isn't it jesse
you know you can speak about media bias
and all the rest of it but when you see
it laid bare
like this here's a guy that was embraced
in a way that
was really obscene it was so gushy
michael avenatti
uh michael avenatti and then it turns
out he's just a
you know a just a low life you have
street smarts this table has street
smarts
we could smell his cheap cologne from a
mile away
we saw it coming but they don't have
street smarts
over in these mainstream media hallways
they get duped
but remember smollett yes oh yeah i'm
hungry for a subway sandwich at 40 below
come on man and they believe the guy a
week later
and then this guy his little shady legal
maneuvers
pulling fake victims out of his hat to
destroy
kavanaugh he was sucking up to everybody
all this grandiosity
they got suckered into this guy they
hitched a wagon to a criminal
carnival barker because they load trump
and they thought this was going to be
the silver bullet
and when i noticed that guy was almost
on tv as much as fouchy
when you see people on tv that much as
much as fauci
and as much as avenatti there's always a
big big crash
kill me you better be careful well
unless you're selling a book unless
you're selling a book i don't care about
stormy i'm glad this guy's going to jail
you know why they can't
smell out this guy this you know a steam
and bag of skeeve that you could
a bag of cicadas right
they can't sniff him out because they
are him
they are the combination yes they're
dip-witted
and arrogant what how else do you
explain this
idiot goes to nikes like i'm gonna
outsmart
the lawyers at nike they're all the same
it's a party of one hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else